[Music]
[Applause]
we
did it we made it through our first week
of this show together
i don't think i've ever had this much
fun in my entire life and i hope
that you have enjoyed this week too
that's the whole point of all of this
let's turn to our virtual friends and
family
are bffs
how fun is that emily can i ask you a
question who is your favorite guest this
week
i loved your interview with charlize it
was so
natural and organic and part of the
genuine conversation i loved it
oh i'm so happy to hear that it's so
nice to hear feedback
you know it gives us a sense of what
people are liking or connecting to
it's really important thank you for
sharing i mean it
you know what spoiler alert all of the
guests were my favorite
okay it's true
i'm so excited for today's guest too
billy porter is here
and he is nominated for another emmy
this weekend in fact i even wore this
outfit for him because i mean he is the
king of style
also today the mom behind this viral
photo opens up about her son's struggle
with distance learning
something a lot of us can relate to this
photo
went crazy and we get to talk to her
today
but first let's get into some drew's
news
[Applause]
excuse me sir ma'am guy
tell me your story
ma'am i asked you a question
this is drew's news
this is true's news it's drew's news
fun fact the dog in the truth news
monologue opener
that's lucy my dog all right now let's
see what made the papers
okay first up the deseret news
reports on a new study from brigham
young
looking at why girls love disney
princesses so much
they surveyed a large group of girls and
found that they connected to them
for four reasons okay their virtues
their royalty
their aspirational lives okay
and their rebellious spirits hmm
[Music]
i can relate to that last one
so can my daughter olive trust me
the thing about this though that really
speaks to me
is it reminds me of making a movie
called ever after
thanks guys the reason ever after
changed my life is because as a girl we
read fairy tales and we're a little
conditioned to wait
to be rescued and this film totally
flipped the script
pun intended on that for me it's like
we still want love at the end of the day
you still want the prince
you still want all the romance but the
point is to get yourself
there and for me to have that revelation
that
in my early 20s that we don't wait to be
rescued
we rescue ourselves well it changed the
entire course of the rest of my
professional
and personal life and i just want to
thank disney because i think you've
really modernized fairy tales for young
girls out there
we no longer wait to be rescued we do
want love in the prince at the end of
the day don't get us wrong
but you've shown us that we can dream
big princess
and be capable and we need stories that
remind us of just that
so thank you
so okay in transition our next story
requires you to loosen that belt buckle
cause it's some time
for food news
okay this story totally spoke to me
because my girls get so excited when i
say
we're going to the gas station it's kind
of their favorite place to eat
it's true come on there's so many treats
and snacks they love it
so check this out girls 7-eleven is
getting in on the action with a new line
of
autumnal sandwich cookies they've got
pumpkin spice they've got salted
caramel they've even got ye old candy
corn
all sold by the sleeve and i've got some
right here that's right
apparently this is called a sleeve i
just learned that too
all right let's taste test the candy
corn ye old candy corn
oh hey bffs nathan ashley you want to
get it on on the action
i heard you ran out to 7-eleven and pick
some up to taste test with me
hi drew yeah we just got back we got
some candy corn
we can't wait to try it and also pumpkin
spice
cheers cookie cheers what do you guys
think
yeah i think they taste pretty much
exactly like candy corn maybe a little
bit sweeter
but they're great i definitely taste the
pumpkin not as much spice but
it's good i'm gonna say winner winner
chicken dinner
i'm in and thank you nathan and ashley
for being culinary guinea pigs with me
okay now it is time for our drew's news
astrology report
[Music]
[Applause]
so here to help us read the stars is
astrologer extraordinaire
aliza kelly hi elisa
drew thank you so much for having me
congratulations
thank you so much this is so exciting it
is
so exciting and it's like first week
done
got it okay here we go and we get to go
into the weekend
with you and i want to ask september
what's going on well you launched at the
perfect time
because we are actually in a
transitional moment right now so on
september 22nd
we are beginning libra season it's the
autumn equinox
so we're moving into a reflective
thoughtful energy
we're going to see a little less sun but
this means that we're going to be our
own
sun we're going to generate our own
radiance and we're going to
learn to understand ourselves from a
different perspective
elisa can i ask you what a birth chart
is
it is basically a snapshot of the sky at
someone's or something's exact time of
birth
so using the birth chart we could see
the rising the sun
and the moon and we can really
understand who that person is or
if it's an event what that person or
what that event is all about
well speaking of birth charts i heard
you maybe have a surprise for us
i do i do okay so i know that this is
your launch week
i know that you just launched on
september 14th so
i decided to look at the astrology for
the drew barrymore show it's like having
a birth chart for basically our third
my third child yes okay tell us what is
it
so you have a beautiful third child uh
the third child
is a libra rising so this is perfect
it's beautiful
it's about balance it's about harmony
it's about symmetry
and it's also a very social energy so
it's about
sharing the stage it's about you giving
basically a space for others to be able
to
share their stories too it's all about
that scales of balance
oh my gosh that's exactly what our
mission is here it's perfect
okay wait okay what about our rising sun
so the sun
is a virgo for the drew barrymore show
and what i really love about this
is that you are a pisces i am and virgo
and pisces are
opposite signs but opposite in astrology
is actually a very
wonderful thing because it means the
goal is the same
just different ways of getting there so
you and the show are basically have the
same mission
which it which is how can i make the
world a better place
and how about the moon
yes so the moon is also a very important
part of the astrology it is
sort of what's going on on the inside it
is the emotional inner world and in this
case it's really showing us the backbone
of the show and it's leo
which is all about entertaining and
theatricality
and passion and really having fun so at
the end of the day
we're going to find balance we're going
to
help people we're going to use
communication and we're also going to
have a great time and look fabulous
while we're doing it so
that's a pretty good chart i would say
elisa
it's a good chart and you know what i
did i hope it's okay
not to add more onto your pleat but um i
asked my mom if she would give me the
exact time i was born
it's 11 51 a.m and i've never had my
chart done
could i have it uh-uh oh my goodness
i we have to do this right now could i
ask you to do my
chart and we could come back on the show
and talk about it
it's a yes from me it's a big yes right
here
thank you thank you thank you i really
appreciate it